to build a website you only need three
ingredients html css and javascript
that sounds pretty straightforward on
the surface but here's the problem
nobody just uses html css and javascript
to build a website
you might replace javascript with
typescript then throw in a ui library
like react
to replace html you'll definitely need a
css preprocessor like sas
then you'll need to import a whole bunch
of third-party modules so you're not
doing everything from scratch many of
your dependencies might use common js
which isn't going to work with your
modern es module syntax the code will
have name collisions all over the place
and even if you do manage to get it to
work you'll likely end up with a massive
javascript file which then needs to be
minified
and broken into smaller chunks just so
people can visit your site with a
reasonable load time you'll also need to
create different versions of your
javascript and load polyfills to ensure
that your code works on legacy browsers
as a developer it's like being asked to
land on the moon with a lawn chair and
some balloons tied to it
it's truly the most annoying aspect of
building a web application
but thankfully we have module bundlers
which make this entire process
a little less annoying in today's video
you'll learn everything you ever wanted
to know about module bundlers
like webpack roll up parcel and snowpack
we'll primarily focus on webpack because
it's the most popular
but most of the core concepts that we'll
look at apply to all of them but make
sure to watch until the end when we look
at snowpack
because it uses a technique that is much
different than the others and represents
what i think will be the future of front
end web development if you're new here
like and subscribe and consider becoming
a pro member at fireship io or sponsor
me on github for even more content let's
start by answering the question of what
is a module bundler
i already presented a long list of
problems and the role of the module
bundler is to fix these problems
the most fundamental thing they do is
take multiple javascript files
and combine them into a single large
file that can be then used in the
browser to load your javascript app
this file or the javascript bundle as
it's called contains your source code
along with any third-party dependencies
that you've imported
your dependencies also likely have their
own dependencies that need to be
imported
a bundler like webpack creates a
dependency graph to keep track of how to
put everything together
you just tell webpack where to find your
entry point and it will look at all of
your imports and dependencies and try to
piece everything together into that
single file
the best way to really learn how this
process works is to do it yourself
go ahead and open up vs code and we'll
do everything step by step so you can
follow along with this video
from an empty directory create an
index.js file in the source directory
now currently this file doesn't have any
dependencies so there's no need for a
module bundler we could simply run this
file with node or directly in the
browser
things get more complicated when we add
dependencies like those from node
package manager
run the command npm init flag y to
create a package.json file
now let's install the world's most
dependent on javascript library lowdash
when we run npm install it adds node
modules here to the root directory
and then adds lowdash to the
dependencies object in the package.json
now what we want to build here is a
frontend web application so i'll create
a public directory
and inside that directory add an
index.html file i'll add some initial
html boilerplate then in the head of the
document
add a script tag that references our
index.js file
now currently our javascript code isn't
using lowdash or any dependencies yet
if we view this file in the browser you
can see we get our hello world console
logged here without any errors but now
let's go back to our code and see what
happens when we try to use a dependency
from lowdash
we'll go ahead and import the camelcase
function and then camelcase our
console.log
now let's go back to the browser and try
to view our website you'll notice we get
an error in the console
the reason we get this error is because
the browser doesn't know how to resolve
the low dash code in other words you're
asking it to find something
but it has no idea where to find it and
that's where something like webpack can
help us out
to use it we first need to install it as
a development dependency
we'll install the webpack cli along with
webpack itself
now most often when you bundle your
production code you'll use a script here
in the package.json file we'll give the
script a name of build
and it simply calls the webpack command
at this point we can execute our script
and run webpack
by entering npm run build from the
command line webpack will analyze the
code in our index.js file
and then compile it to a dist main.js
file which is our production code
or the code that we would ship to the
end user in the browser so with that
being said
let's go into our index.html file and
we'll change the path in our script tag
to point to the main.js file if we
reload the browser the error should be
gone
and we should see hello world in
camelcase congratulations you just
bundled your first module
it's important to note that we're
currently using the default webpack
config
and by default it looks for the source
index.js file
if your files name something else it
won't work in most cases though
you'll want or need to customize the
behavior of webpack in which case
you can create a webpack config file the
file itself is a javascript module
that exports an object that customizes
the behavior of webpack
let's take a look at some of the most
important parts of the object so you're
not totally confused if you're the
unfortunate developer who has to modify
the webpack config
the first attribute is entry which
defines the entry point to your
application
in our case that's the index.js file in
the source directory
it's also worth noting that entry can be
an object to support multiple entry
points you might see this used to
support a technique called code
splitting
so they're only loaded on the pages that
actually need that code it's beyond the
scope of this video but it's just good
to know what code splitting means
from there we have output which is the
name of the file that we want to compile
our javascript to
by default it's main.js but we may want
to change it to something else
and when determining the file location
we can use node.js utilities like path
to resolve a consistent path name now if
we go ahead and run the build command
again
you'll notice it outputs our bundle to a
file called awesome.js
that's pretty straightforward but you
often have more to worry about than just
javascript when building a full web
application
let's make things a little more
interesting by adding an scss file to
our code
not only is this file not javascript but
it also needs to be compiled by the sas
compiler
we can make the file known to webpack by
importing it in our index.js file
but when we try to compile our code
you'll notice we get an error that says
module parse failed currently no loaders
are configured to process this file
but what is a loader exactly in webpack
a loader is a way to
pre-process a file in our case we want
to import some css code
then tell our javascript to inject that
css in the dom when our web application
is loaded
essentially loaders provide a way to
handle any kind of file that's not plain
javascript
loaders exist for pretty much every use
case you can imagine including
typescript markdown
and various css preprocessors in our
case we're going to use three different
loaders
style loader css loader and sas loader
we can install these packages in our
development environment then we'll go
back to our webpack config
then add the module attribute in this
section we can add one or more rules
that will match a certain file type
to the required loaders the rule itself
will have a test attribute
that is a regular expression that
matches any file that ends in
scss when webpack encounters one of
these files it can use the following
loaders
to process the scss into regular css and
then to javascript so it can eventually
be injected into an html page
let's go ahead and save the config and
then run our build command again when we
open the output
main.js we can search through it and
we'll find our css code embedded here
loaders will likely do most of the heavy
lifting for you in webpack
but you can also tap into the webpack
compiler directly using its plugin
system
a plugin allows you to tap into the
entire compilation lifecycle
we're not going to build a plug-in from
scratch in this video but we'll look at
how to use one of my favorite open
source plugins
the webpack bundle analyzer we can
install it with npm and it will tell us
exactly how big our javascript bundle is
and which dependencies are contributing
to its size
in our webpack config we'll first import
the bundle analyzer plugin
then we'll go down and create a plugins
array and instantiate the plugin there
now if we run the build command again it
will bring up this visualization of our
javascript bundle as you can see here
loadash is taking up the majority of the
space and we can optimize that by only
installing the actual functions from
lodash that we really need for the app
now one annoying thing that we've been
doing at this point is running the npm
build command
every time we make a change another way
bundlers help you out is by setting up a
local dev server to watch changes to
your project and recompile them
so you don't have to do it manually
first we'll use npm to install webpack
dev server then we'll go into our
webpack config
and use the dev server option to
configure the files that we want to
serve
and the port that they should be served
on you can also configure the server for
compression
and hot module replacement in any case
we likely want to add another
npm script at this point we'll go ahead
and give it a name of dev and it will
run the webpack serve command
if we go ahead and run that script with
npm run dev you'll notice it loads up a
server on localhost 9000
and it will also watch the source
directory for any changes and recompile
anytime we save a file so hopefully that
gives you enough to get started with
webpack without feeling overwhelmed
other popular module bundlers like
rollup and parcel
are very similar to webpack but try to
achieve the same result with less
configuration
those are definitely tools you should be
aware of but what i want to focus on
next
is a relatively new bundler called
snowpack one thing you might have
noticed when we were using webpack
is that it took a while to compile all
of our code each file change would take
about four seconds to compile our css
and javascript into a new bundle and it
can be a super annoying waste of time
especially on larger projects snowpack
takes a different approach to handling
modules and development
instead of recompiling on every change
it builds all of your dependencies once
and then ships them directly to the
browser that means when you make a
change to your javascript code
it can be reflected in the browser
instantly snowpack only needs to rebuild
one file instead of going through the
entire dependency graph
this is really awesome when you have a
big complex project because as your
project grows bigger
your build times don't they stay
consistently fast i've been using it for
a personal project of mine and the
developer experience has been awesome so
i'd highly recommend checking it out for
your next project
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe
and consider becoming a pro member at
fireship io for more advanced content
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one